ensemble jacques brel gérard geneste
bien de toi ça non ah c'est pas de lui
tiens pour une fois c'est pas de lui une
source révèle tout seul et ça s'appelle
vieille pour l'art on va voter ce fait
c'est biya qui nous ont tous nos bâtons
notre régénère ce n'est le plus prenant
de résine c'est pour pouvoir enfin voter
le caire à ceux qui nous valent et le
niveau qu'ils n'ont père un raider
lentilles longueur ennuyeux c'est pour
cela j'en comprends moins c'est veille
les achats depuis reviennent
repos voir un jour en fallait revenir à
celle qui me jugent avec qui furent r on
en croit niasse c'est pour pouvoir ou si
je mens pardon
c'est pour pouvoir leur révérence et
matra qui mille fois m'ont condamné
comme en plus on vous pardonne
pour qu'ils n'avaient même pas pêcher
ses passages en coffret massa s'éveille
le désir ardent de venir viennent
pour pouvoir au jardin de mon jeune le
soigner que me souvenais donner le temps
femme peut s'attendre
et le plus jalouse et même ses propos
graves
enfin chanter l'amour sur la citadelle
quand même et pour qu'enfin on me fasse
la cour pour d'autres causes que mes
fesses eux c'est pour sagem jambes qu'au
fond de moi
cb
le vih à devenir bière